SPEAKER: Since leaping into
the world of serverless,
Critter Junction's been
reaching new limits.
But I've got a few tricks to
take it up to the next level.
Stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
A core promise of serverless
compute platforms,
like Cloud Run and
Cloud Functions,
is that you don't need to worry
about your infrastructure.
Your service scales
automatically.
That works great when your
whole stack autoscales.
But what if your
service depends on API
or databases with rate
or connection limits?
That's what happened
with Critter Junction's
new companion app code
named the Wallet app.
It allows users to send and
receive virtual currency
over a marketplace.
Every time a user
sends or receives cash,
the change to the user
Wallet data in the database
kicks off a Cloud Function
to return a confirmation.
Cloud Function is a lightweight,
serverless compute solution
that lets you create single
purpose and standalone
functions that respond
to cloud events.
And because serverless compute
products are stateless,
they use Cloud SQL, a fully
managed relational database
service for stateful data,
like user Wallet amounts.
After the Wallet app gained
popularity because of YouTube
live streamers, Cloud SQL's
maximum connection limit
was reached.
And that meant the
upstream functions
weren't able to provide knew
Wallet amount confirmations.
So my team came in to
give them a few tips
to scale the Wallet app
and any future serverless
workloads they plan to deploy.
Let's review how
serverless functions
scale as you take a function
from your local computer
to the cloud.
A function takes inputs and
provides an output response.
That function can be
repeated with many inputs
and provide many outputs.
A serverless platform manages
the elastic horizontal scaling
of function instances.
Because Google Cloud can
give you near infinite scale,
that can have consequences
for other systems
that your function
interacts with.
So what do you do?
Well, a lot of what
I'm about to tell you
involves applying
limits to operations
to protect underlying
services and resources.
First off, you can configure
instance scaling limits
to your functions.
Cloud Functions offer
max instance settings.
This feature limits how
many concurrent instances
of your functions are running
and attempting to establish
database connections.
So if your database
can only handle
100 concurrent connections, you
might set your max instances
to a lower value, say 75.
Since each instance
of a function
can only handle a single
request at a time,
this means you can only
handle 75 concurrent requests
at a given time, saving your
database from maxing out
at its rate limit
even during a spike.
Second, use Cloud Tasks to
limit the rate of work done.
Sometimes, the limit
you're worried about
isn't the number of
concurrent connections,
but the rate at which
work is performed.
For example, imagine you need
a call to an external API that
has limited per minute quota.
Cloud Tasks's a
fully managed service
that lets you manage
the execution, dispatch,
and delivery of
distributed tasks.
You can manage the
way work gets done
and perform the work outside of
the serverless handlers in work
queues.
Cloud Tasks supports rate
and concurrency limits.
So regardless of its rate
at which work arrives,
it's performed
with rates applied.
For example, if large influx
of API requests come in,
Cloud Tasks can buffer the
rate at which your request can
be handled by the API.
Third, use stateful storage
to defer the results
from long-running operations.
Sometimes, you
want your functions
to be able to defer work
that might take a while,
but still give a
response to the caller
that the task was received.
You want to send the results
of the task to the caller
eventually, also known as
long-running operations.
For example, it
might not make sense
to encode a large video file
inside a serverless instance.
You could use Cloud Tasks if
the caller of your workload
only needs to know that
their request was submitted.
But if you want the caller
to be able to retrieve
a status or eventual
result, you need
an additional stateful
system to track that job.
There are several ways
you can do this using
combination of Cloud Functions,
Cloud Pub/Sub, and Firestore.
While Critter Junction has just
started to explore serverless
with cloud native apps, like
the layout and wallet apps,
they're constantly revisiting
how to improve performance
and scalability, like using
max serverless instances,
Cloud Tasks to limit
the rate of work,
and stateful storage for
long-running operations.
For more details on these tips
and an awesome decision tree,
check out the link below.
And stay tuned for our next
serverless scaling tips.
And remember, always
be architecting.
[MUSIC PLAYING]